We're always trying to step up our game to see if we can get the craziest camera techniques possible
And that's something that I'm gonna try to do today ready to see it. Tikka. I'm like so excited
I've been wanting to do this for a while
All right now it's no secret that I'm a big fan of 360 cameras
We've made a lot of videos about them. If you haven't seen them go check them out
They allow you to do all kinds of crazy camera moves like this or even this look at me
I'm also a big fan of drones. I love flying them
I love making videos with them but something that I haven't done yet is put a 360 camera on a racing drone
Now by putting a 360 camera on a racing drone
I'm hoping I'll be able to discover some really sweet new camera moves that can really step our game up for our next
Anime film these are some of my favorite videos we've made because they combine just the most absurd
storytelling with just the craziest camera moves
We've used like GoPro gimble's to get really fast
But smooth motion and we're always trying to step up our game and see if we can get the craziest camera techniques possible
But before we proceed let me talk about what racing drones even are. Now, you're probably familiar with something that looks like this
This is a classic DJI phantom and they're part of a whole breed of drones that are meant for smooth
Cinematography, however, the flight characteristics of a cinema drone like this is very limited
They can't really do all that much unlike a racing drone like this
Which on top of being very fast is also incredibly acrobatic you could do barrel rolls and flips and get all kinds of crazy cameras
Camera moves. It's a little like comparing a commercial airliner to a fighter jet
I'm hoping this will allow us to get some incredibly dynamic shots
You know, this is actually a video I've been wanting to do for quite some time
but I've been very hesitant up until this point because the 1x is
Honestly, like pretty much my favorite camera and if I crash there's a very real chance
I'll break it fortunately today
Insta 360 has agreed to sponsor this video so that if I do crash and break the camera, they'll replace it for me
That takes out a lot of worry about breaking. My equipment makes me feel better about doing crazier stuff
So and with your track record and what what?
Excuse me
If sneezing let the thief I got it back oh
Yeah
All right
so I was debating whether I should put it on the
Buzz or the new one and I've decided to go with the new one cuz I want to fly HD, but here's the thing
I have an idea on how to mount it
I just don't know how well it's gonna work guy named Newark who is a drone racing league pilot actually came up with this idea
It's a classic GoPro mount
So this quarter inch screw thread here will actually mount perfectly with the 360 camera
So this is the idea. It's got sticky stuff on the bottom of the mountain
I'm just gonna stick this to the drone and then put some zip ties around us to secure it in place
Hopefully that'll work. This is about the same way as a GoPro Hero 7 but here's the thing
That concerns me Nick. It's not so much the weight of it as much as the weight distribution
You see this is a really tall dude here. You know it brings the center of gravity a little further up
So it's gonna actually perform a little differently than what I'm used to and I put the battery on backwards. Dang it
So here is the camera put on it. I'm really excited. Dude. I'm like so excited
I've been wanting to do this for a while. You have to take this to the streets or this park in the parks
Here's my transmitter this is how I control the drone for the goggles, this is how I see where the drums going
I'm pretty much ready to fly it let's get this thing in the air
Okay, let's let's get the safety ready to see it take off
You're up
Alright, it's flying. I'm felt any difference in flight characteristics just yet, but I haven't pushed it very hard yet
I'm gonna do a flyby ready
Yeah, it's definitely requiring more thrust to stay in the air which makes sense it's heavier, do you know, okay
Yeah, definitely. It's got a big butt. He's got a big fat butt big show you oh
That's landing that was landing. Huh? Not a bad flight
Like that actually flew surprisingly well, okay for the next battery, I'm gonna try to do some flips and rolls and power loops
Oh
I
hit a tree
Oh
No, it's just been it's just that look at that
That's straight nap you cut this branch off
This prop is bent but the Emax ones are so durable, I can literally bend it back and they will keep flying
Ren came to me this morning with a big smile on his face. He said Nick
I've been flying all weekend, and I got some sweet footage to show you
So this right here is the raw
Stitched footage from the camera because you have one video clip from one lens and another video clip from the other lens and the program
Automatically stitches this stuff that used to be a huge process back of the day. I'm glad it's not process anymore
But what we're seeing here is what's called an every rectangular image
I'm so proud of you guys. You know, like when you're looking at a map of the earth and Greenland and Canada look huge
That's because he take a globe essentially slice it down the middle unwrap it and flatten it, okay
So here's the first flight remember the one that I tried to go really really slow and steady on I was expecting a lot more
Vibrations, but I didn't really get many and the camera is able to stabilize out pretty much most of the motion
This is the easiest effect to do with the camera
which is the tiny planet effect think of like taking like the most fish eye lens possible and then pointing it straight down it can
Still see all the different directions, but because of that it creates this weird curved look
So another aspect of this is that you can actually choose your field of view to be
Incredibly wide way wider than a GoPro. This is closer to like a typical GoPro style. Look except it's also stabilized
There's not really any picture roll motion
I
Mean it's cool about this is that you can essentially take one shot and end up with whole variety of shots from that one run
What the heck
That motion blurs. Oh man is so cool
My favorite part about doing this style of camera move is the incredible sense of speed it produces. I did this on my phone
I literally transferred the footage from the 1x to my phone over Wi-Fi
Processed it there and then exported it to my phone
It makes it really easy and great for just uploading directly to Instagram or Facebook
It's really nice speaking of which if you follow the corridor digital Instagram, it's right there
You'll have already seen a lot of this footage that's been posted the links below you right now was
So another really cool aspect that doing something like this allows me is to choose my framing after the fact whatever
Orientation and zoom that I want here. I can turn on what's called pre capture and now I can actually like look around
So I was just flying along and there's some cars driving up and down this road and I was careful enough to fly up next
to the car
however
I could still stare at the car no matter where I flew
It looks it looks very cinematic. When I do it that way until the of course the drone gets into the show
There's a huge amount of freedom there and makes me just really want to go shoot a test
I don't think it's worth doing a full-on like narrative thing, but more like a proof of concept narrative piece
I think you could follow a frisbee in there
Yeah
I've never
Chased something that's been thrown before so I don't know if it's gonna be really easy or if it's gonna be a challenge
So when doing a narrative cinematic thing, you don't want to see the drone at all
Even if it does look cool, so I had an idea I found this in the in the closet
So this is I haven't tested this but I think it'll be fine. This was attached down here. But now it's up here
How is it gonna balance, dude?
Hey, man
Drones are powerful by putting extra distance between the lens of the camera and the props of the drone itself
It will now appear much smaller in frame. I'm really hoping this works. We should go to the park
So, unfortunately, these are not the best frisbees to actually play catch with they're meant for frisbee golf
So far, I was unimpressed with throws that I've been seeing. How am I supposed to track a long distance throw? Yeah
I'm gonna try throwing it as far as I can you ready?
Get the fire extinguishers
My name is scythe winder
Come back so just to begin
I think we should just do some shots where we literally do our just throwing the frisbee as far as they can
I will just try to do my best to actually like track that so I'm gonna get my little extension pole out
This is mighty ridiculous. It's just wrong, man
Only have four flights I say we do it
Oh looks a little wobbly it is a little wobbly though
Go
This is gonna be a challenge try it time to throw with like five I ready
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait, I
Was definitely not ready
Yeah, so it turns out this is gonna be way harder than I expected my battery's done I gotta come in for landing
The card really oh, yeah very hard Oh mom
It's just really hard to guess where the frisbees gonna go and how fast is gonna get there. It's unpredictable with the wind and everything
What if we just do a couple controlled shots? Maybe Wes and I time it - you imagine this is Wes right here
It's imagine. This is Nick you guys are here and you're throwing the frisbee between E - Mm-hmm
I'm just gonna be flying the drone just up and down beside you guys here. So I'll be like
Alright keep throwing but try to throw it in sync with me go on by you know, yes
Yes
This is great. Oh my god, they're having their best catches yet
We're finally starting to sync up on how is actually a flying by while they're throwing and they are catching it
I think we got some sweet shots there
I felt like you got some great set up moments and even some froze see back at the studio
We have the footage and unfortunately, we ran into an issue. That was my fault. I didn't properly calibrate the camera
When you calibrate the camera you go through the menu hit calibrate you put it here
Then he hit calibrate and that's how it knows where the horizon is. This is level when I calibrated it
I did it like this
So that meant that all of the footage was like 90 degrees
Sideways, and I couldn't change the horizon
And that meant that I couldn't use my phone to actually do the free capture and the desktop software
Wasn't able to help me there either. So it's all the footage gone. Can we use the footage?
It's positive this cause is too long for me. Okay. Here's the thing
It was some extra work that I gave myself by doing this wrong, but we got some pretty sweet shoppe
We know the potential that this camera can give you from a racing drunk perspective, but for a narrative standpoint here specifically check this up
You see the technique behind that suit is beautiful and the cameras, okay?
Yeah, this could definitely cut in can be like a good character intro like yeah, I like that
Ah, I like a little charged up shot. See what's nice about this
Is that not only can you look anywhere you want I'm able to actually like zoom in
That's awesome. I feel like if we were actually to make an anime frisbee short
We would just use the drone as the camera and then add a CG frisbee know what honestly that's the way we should have done
It is just out of CG frisbee and the other definite problem
I found when doing this is that even though the One X has like almost 6k resolution
To see the frisbee after crop in so tight we're looking at like a 240p version
So the camera definitely shines the wider your field of view is so the system is like super cool for getting those sweet
Establishing shots. My biggest takeaway is don't screw yourself by I'm calibrating your camera
But secondly, we needed to play to the strengths of this camera, which is big movements big
Objects in frame animate frisbee wasn't really the right use case for a camera like this
We definitely learned the limitations of this rig if we want to incorporate this for some specific shots in a narrative video
We now know that that's exactly what we have to do and we can't just use the whole bang thing on it
So we're always trying to like push the bounds of what we can even try and do here and you know, what?
We're not gonna stop we're gonna continue experimenting. So make sure you subscribe. I did shoot a bunch of other footage
So if you want to see some pretty sweet stuff
Stay tuned right now